oh hi I'm about to shoot a Valentine's
Day video but I'm trying to Google a
heart so I can have a nice background so
you guys could just hold on one second
while I find the perfect heart we can
get this show on the road
images cool that nice that looks great
let's just Center this up real nice
there's my oatmeal from earlier this
morning oh this is gonna be a great
video hey guys how's it going happy
Valentine's Day I hope you guys are
having a fantastic day it's another day
it's the same day as it was the day
before anyway I asked you guys on
Twitter what video I should make for
Valentine's Day I got so many different
suggestions so when I go through and try
to hit on every topic the first
suggestion is for my sister who said
that I should talk about girls on
Valentine's Day I'm a girl I'm very much
a girl but I am one of those girls that
I really think Valentine's Day is kind
of stupid basically what I'm saying is
if your guy is only nice to you on
Valentine's Day then you're gonna need
to rethink your relationship and the one
thing that absolutely drives me nuts is
seeing you post the things on Facebook
that you're a boyfriend husband
significant other gave to you now it's
one thing to post like oh look at this
nice necklace that he got me look this
great ring but when you set up an entire
photo shoot for these items you set the
bed down you put the little dust bag
overtop of it you put the wrist the gift
receipt so that we can see how much it
costs you put the bag you go and get
some studio lighting so you can take the
perfect photograph of your gift to post
on Facebook drives me nuts back I'm
gonna go on to the next suggestion from
Adam who wants me to talk about the
overly obnoxious things that you see on
Valentine's Day I mean these Yuri
commercials are so a lot of it and I've
noticed that my heart is no longer up I
just saw these jewelry commercials oh my
god can't stand it my god fuller just
can't stand them you're so obnoxious and
just so overly not even realistic like
give me some bit of realism ah I tried
it crazy let me hurt when I get myself
ahead
next next one moving along Miriam listen
I would if we have to spend Valentine's
Day alone my best advice for anyone who
was actually looking to be in a
relationship is when you're not looking
that relationship will find you promise
you that's how it always happens so for
all of you who are looking for something
to do if you happen to be alone on
Valentine's Day find some more of your
single friends go out get a drink if
you're not old enough to drink by drink
I don't mean you have to have alcohol
you can have a coca-cola you can have a
Pepsi you can have some coffee
go celebrate with your single friends
hello ladies huh sing the ways and have
fun you don't really depends if do you
want to be having a sad sad melted rumba
happy Valentine's Day go do all of your
favourite things where your favorite
color go buy yourself your favorite
candy go eat your favorite food do you
like animals go to the zoo go to the pet
store play with some kitties would I
even just say right there I didn't even
know next next question says how do you
get ready for Valentine's Day
well if you do haven't have a
Valentine's Day date um you're probably
gonna want to look your best so go and
dig through your closet try on a lot of
clothes find which one makes you feel
and look as sexy as possible and as far
as makeup goes I'm pretty sure every
beauty guru has made a date night makeup
video so pretty sure you can find some
ideas in some of those videos good I
don't have any for you love me for who I
am
Roth wants to meet a DAC about why it's
so expensive to send flowers or go out
to eat on Valentine's Day it is
expensive like flowers are so expensive
and guess what happens they die ah
something else make them
make a flower bouquet out of paper show
your lady or man you're capable of being
crafty spend a little extra time and
write some secret little notes on the
inside of those flower bouquets I have
no idea what I'm saying right now to be
completely honest with you so let's go
onto the next question
I lied on dipstick Oh Peter self wants
to know how to cope with Valentine's Day
without alcohol
um well don't drink it
another what to do if you're alone on
Valentine's Day honestly guys if you're
alone and breaks it don't do something
for you
I am maybe I'm a strange person but I
absolutely love to go to either lunch or
dinner by myself and I love watching
people like I'm a people watcher like
I'm a creeper I'll go sit there eating
dinner by myself just like I always go
to this one restaurant after I go to the
gym or yoga class and it's a super fancy
restaurant so I roll up in my sweatpants
and sweaty and disgusting and my yoga
mat and I'm just like Here I am I'm
ready to have my salad and my bread and
creep on people I actually probably
wouldn't suggest you to go to dinner
alone on Valentine's Day because it may
feel a little awkward but this is going
to be the perfect opportunity for you to
order some food in get crazy or you
could even make yourself a nice little
dinner I don't know how to cook so I
don't know I'm really not very good at
giving advice oh here's one from David
who is saying how to deal with
Valentine's Day when you've been dumped
a few weeks before it all right here's
what I would do okay
I would take all those memories of your
significant other and I would start a
fire in a safe location where you're
allowed to start a fire of course and I
would just burn there things don't know
how to use that
tell me more tell me more honor tomorrow
our love Oh God dangerous this bad yeah
double ever do that ever that is a bad
idea
Oh God nice question
thank god there's no more questions ah
put my little heart back up here and
wish you all a happy Valentine's Day but
in all seriousness if you are alone on
Valentine's Day
guys it's just another day it's really
not a big deal make it about you go and
do something that you've always wanted
to do draw some pictures dance dancing
always makes you feel great I will
actually be alone on Valentine's Day too
because I will be traveling so my
friends we will uh team hashtag forever
alone so let's just all roll up to the
scene with their ceiling missing and
they're gonna be like where's your
ceiling at and I'll be like I'll ow
hello
roll up do the same but mostly the
missing what did I even talk about this
video I have no idea I'm actually afraid
to edit this police not a Harlem shake
video kiss yeah see ya later happy
Valentine's Day I love you